c'est pourquoi l'on travaille un petit
sujet de pascal misrahi sur l'historique
du logo d'air france
la création de ce nouveau logo depuis
l'image scandale public août 1933 un
curieux petit symbole apparaît sur les
avion d'une compagnie qui vient de se
créer c'est un hippocampe et les
incident le symbolise en l'air et la mer
à une époque où étaient encore exploité
les hydravions
depuis on a retrouvé ce monstre marin
sur tous les types d'appareils de la
compagnie du jeune choeur robriguez
jusqu'au super constellation et aux
décès 3 il a volé dans tous les cieux du
monde sur tous les continents
il a été le premier à voler sur des
avions à réaction et il a été le premier
à franchir le mur du son aujourd'hui
encore cette hip hop en utiliser et
modernisé accompagne à l'avant des
appareils le logo actuel d'air france
depuis 1976 lors de la mise en service
de concorde
tous les avions de la flotte ont été
repensés repeint pour mieux correspondre
à l'image de marque de la compagnie
par cette nouvelle image en fait elle
était quand même extrêmement pensée
maman vous en doutez on est on est parti
finalement d'un impératif qui était
celui de permettre à la compagnie d'être
reconnu sur tous les aéroports du monde
ce qui n'était pas forcément le cas
avant et de véhiculer une identité
nationale c'est à dire qu'on puisse dire
que ce soit en comble sans je laisse ça
c'est un avion qui vient de france en
fait pour créer l'image de la france en
a travaillé dans de multiples directions
une des directions s'était par exemple
aef qui est le symbole l'iata le symbole
international de france et si on n'a pas
retenu c'est parce qu'effectivement il
nous paraissait être relativement aux
proches d'autres d'autres façons ils ont
d'autres compagnies s'exprime on est on
a plutôt eu tendance à travailler sur
des symboles abstraits c'est d'ailleurs
des couleurs et des lignes parce que ne
paraissait plus intéressant de
différencier les avions d'air france par
rapport aux autres compagnies par ce
moyen là des couleurs et des lignes
l'avion dont air france est un avion
blanc y en a pas d'autre il c'est un
avion qui est peint aussi bien dessous
que dessus il n'y en avait pas d'autres
à cette époque là et c'est un avion qui
sur sa dérive à un symbole qui rappelle
le symbole de la france c'est à dire le
top le drapeau bleu blanc rouge avec en
plus quelque chose qui vibre quelque
chose de plus dynamique
une image que l'on retrouve sur tous les
véhicules de piste et deux services
une image omniprésente mais pas toujours
reconnus
un drapeau français bleu blanc rouge sur
français qu'elle soit disposer d'une
façon ou d'une autre cela france une
carte
hier gilles carrez l'inter aurait 21 ter
en gare thiers france
enfin vous fait penser à quoi un voyage
l'avion un ticket d'avion un voyage
si un accusé ment à moi ça me fait pas
personnellement ça fait penser au
drapeau français
qu'est ce que c'est un logo pour vous ne
savez pas
je vous avouerai franchement que ça ça
devrait être un jean sérien sommes enfin
à tout hasard j 7 1 le 10 jeunes
d'afrique du sud ou un truc comme ça non
une campagne d'avis
deux concerts français interne
ça te pensait reprendre